all right tyler
yeah tyler uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh i'm from
southern california uh more specifically
the inland empire or the ie which is out
by san bernardino riverside kind of area
which is
about the halfway point between
uh la and palm springs
out towards the desert tell me about
your family growing up
uh my family was a pretty pretty close
family i have an older brother and an
older sister i'm the youngest i'm the
baby of family
um
[Music]
parents uh separated when i was probably
about fifth grade but still kind of you
know both were around both kind of
trying to
be
be a part of everything but you know not
not together sounds like a pretty good
childhood
yeah decent you know no crazy abuse
uh no no abuse uh
didn't didn't have a lot of money
growing up but uh
my parents you know they always kind of
tried to do the best they could for us
but
yeah good you made it through high
school
yeah
you going anything beyond that
uh
about a semester of college okay and
then and then that stopped and then
years later i actually ended up becoming
uh an employee of that college that i
only spent about a semester at
and what kind of work have you done
since you uh left home uh of course i
started in fast food you know which most
most kids do high school age
uh fast food and then um
went to a little bit of retail
um
selling uh cds and
vhs dvds that type of stuff
and then uh from there i actually went
on to be a counselor at a boys home
uh
it was a facility
i think there was
eight or nine dorms there was probably
about 80 80 kids there wards of the
state or juvenile hall kids that you
know
getting a chance to
rehabilitate you know so i worked there
and then i went to a boy's home which
was
a six bed boys home
and then uh after that
i became a bartender
so i kind of all over the place
and then eventually you started working
at strip clubs i did actually uh my
first bartending job was um
at a place called the moose lodge and
then after that i got a job at a strip
club as a bartender which was fun but
didn't really work out because
this isn't what people go in to see at a
strip club so when you go to the bar
it you know the the tips were never too
good on my side it was always the female
bartenders that got more so i ended up
becoming a dj which was a much better
fit for me your your look scared people
sometimes yeah i guess tell me about all
your piercings and your
your tattoos and all that um growing up
i always wanted to get
tattoos uh
being a fan of music and musicians i was
never really into like comic book
characters or superheroes my superheroes
were
the freddie mercury the axel rose the
the rock stars you know so
growing up in uh in the 80s
motley crew like that was one kind of
tattoos so i always wanted tattoos so as
soon as i turned 18
i got my first tattoo and then
it was done from there yeah but yours
are a little bit beyond just the typical
tattoos yeah you've got things under
your skin i started with the tattoos and
then and then the piercings and then
once i had kind of
done all of that i wanted to see how
much further i could go and uh i
discovered uh hook suspension or flesh
flush suspension
where you take hooks and you
raise the a person up off the ground
and uh you're raising yourself off the
ground with piercings which are attached
where on your body um
the the first place is the back that's
where you start but i've done it uh in
the past 15 years i've done it from the
back
the chest the ribs
above the knees below the knees the
forearms so
there's many places that you can
you can use for a suspension what's the
attraction to that
originally the attraction for me was
just to see if i could do it mentally
and physically and uh then once i did do
it it's just it's a whole lot of fun you
know you get a whole lot of pain too
it's just it's some pain
uh everybody's kind of different some
people don't like the hooking some
people don't like the hanging
you're hanging
like how many hooks
typically
well depends on where you do in
different positions so if you're laying
chest down or stomach down then you
could have
ten hooks in your back and your legs uh
the first time i did it was four in my
back but now i typically do it with two
and how how long would you will you do
this
uh we do
we do private ones and we do public like
shows so that depends i've i've hung for
about an hour and a half before
uh and then 45 minutes half hour so
there's there's many different time
links whether you're doing a performance
or just
a personal one is there something
that you enjoy the shock value of what
you do or what you look like i think
that's kind of what led me to
to become what i've become is i do enjoy
shock values because you have bumps
under your arms and hands yeah that that
came after the suspension once i got
into i did the suspension and then that
kind of that opened up a whole new world
for me
and i i started making friends that had
uh implants
and split tongues and
all different kinds of uh body mod
which it's called your ears are
stretched out my ears yeah they uh when
i have a jewelry and a plug it's a two
inch hole and then you have things in
your forehead too
yes i do uh
currently uh i have flat plates on it
but i can unscrew that
screw in spikes and then i have horns
so that all it it started with
suspension and then it all grew and then
i discovered the
the uh the implants and
just kind of went crazy with it what do
you think it is at its core do you think
it's a call for attention do you think
it's
just trying to shock the the normal i i
think it's kind of
it's it's a shock
for me personally i think it's also kind
of like
maybe an artistic side you know showing
art on on the body i enjoy that
um
i don't wanna i don't necessarily think
it's a call for attention because i
typically don't like attention which
this has really not been
a good idea in that case because it does
draw attention to me but i i do like the
shock of it
and you're going to be misunderstood
which some people i know get off on yeah
uh
yeah but you know everybody
definitely people uh
still today judge a book by its cover
you know so when you look like this
people expect you to be a certain way or
you know be be a bad or mean person
which i i try to
when uh
when i was growing up and i started with
all of this the tattoos and then the
piercings and started growing
uh the one thing that that i was told by
by my mom was uh
you you can look however you want but
just be a good person treat people right
and that's what i always try to do you
know people expect me to sometimes be uh
not a good person but that's why i try
to
go beyond that and try to be you know
i suspect it's almost like you're you're
testing people's notion or understand
beliefs about
you know
you know
a book reading a book by its cover yeah
um
and by doing this you're but but being a
the opposite type of person
you're you're kind of
trying to expose people's
mistaken beliefs yeah yeah i believe so
i'm challenging people to to look beyond
that exactly yeah
so in the club you're now a dj
uh yeah so uh so after bartending and
then becoming a dj that's now that we're
here uh
18 years later 18 years that i've been
been djing but what have you learned
about
people from working at a strip club for
18 years you know there's
there's all different types of people
everywhere um the people i i've met some
of the best people that i've known in my
life through the strip club but i've
also met some of the worst people so
you've got all
types of people everywhere and that's
that's the main thing i've learned you
know everybody
kind of like judging a book you know
people will assume you're in this
industry so you're this type of person
or you you do this and so
that you know your pinhole to that but
uh
it's i mean i some of the
dancers i've worked with are now lawyers
you know i i've i've worked with some
very intelligent
people
just you know
it's it's a job it's an industry but
all different types of people
and i've i've worked
in 18 years i've worked with many
different types of people as far as
physically too i've worked with blind
dancers i've worked with uh
amputee dancers and one girl had one leg
um
deaf
deaf dancers so you know you can find
all types of people in there and it's
really you know most the places i've
worked at it's it's a family it's more
so because i've worked in retail and
i've worked in restaurants and i've
worked in all different types of stuff
no job i've had is really kind of
people look out for each other and take
care of each other as they do in
in that industry from what i've found
and some of the women are doing it for
they're doing it for different purposes
they all do it for different purposes
that you've you've got the party girls
you've got the ones that just you know
can't do a nine to five or or don't want
to and then you've got you've got the
girls that legitimately are working
their way through school and like i said
some have become lawyers and uh
some might be doctors by now i know lots
of nurses and
you know medical assistants have
gone through there but they've
they you know some of them actually are
are working to either support their
family or
or better their life and and go beyond
that you know but then there are the
ones that kind of get get trapped in
there it is
it's
it's a fine line in that industry you
know you could go one way or you can go
the other yeah which uh luckily for me i
i was
far on one side of the line and luckily
i was able to
jump to the other side tell me about
tell me about the men that come into
strip clubs are most of them fooled by
how how friendly the girls are
uh yes
so the first thing everybody tells me
she likes me you've got the greatest job
ever oh
and
of course it's you know i'm not digging
ditches and i'm not sitting in a cubicle
but
i don't get the side that the customer
gets
you know the the customer comes in sits
down and she gets that sweet pretty girl
that sits and rubs his shoulder and asks
if he had a hard day
and then i'm i'm necessarily the
psychiatrist for the girl she comes and
i hear the problems
and i i get the attitude and i get you
know
so
it's uh
it's it's it's a different side of it so
the guys don't see that so um
so so they're definitely like that's the
the only
side they see of it is that
nice friendly pretty side
uh but then also some of the guys that
come in are kind of jerks too you know
like some of the stuff that i've
overheard
guys saying is
pretty pretty crazy you know they feel
the dancer is an object and they can
treat her however they want or the girl
down the street just turned him down so
now he's gonna come and he's gonna make
her feel how he you know
so
but the girls are friendly
so
um
but
it's all about money for the girls
yeah it is entirely i heard a comedian
um i'm i'm not much for telling jokes so
i'm sure i'm gonna destroy it but i
heard a comedian a long time ago say
that
being in a strip club is the best way to
judge how drunk you are because by the
time you've had that final drink and you
start thinking i think she really likes
me she doesn't want my money she
she just wants to have a conversation
with me
that's the point when you know it's time
to go and you've had too much
um
being in the industry that that joke's
always stuck with me because it it's
funny because it is true like i i see
that moment in the guys when they kind
of switch and they're like
i think she really just
she just wants to spend time with me you
know but it's a job
um
definitely so yeah they're they're but
then there are the girls that are there
just for
the party or the good times and kind of
don't care about how much money they
make so like i said that there's all
different types of girls in it are drugs
are part of the uh strip clips drugs
very much uh
unfortunately are a big part of the the
strip club scene
um
you got the late hours so
that always you know and then
being in a club atmosphere it's always
kind of around that and then of course
uh just kind of dealing with the [ __ ]
guys you know
that kind of helps you know a couple
drinks or whatever is going to kind of
help you get through the night so
it is i've seen a lot of people uh
myself included
throughout their time in the strip clubs
become sober uh i started in
2003 was when i started working in strip
clubs and
late in 2008
uh i myself i got sober so you're using
what
um
drinking a lot i worked in an alcohol
club uh in in california
um topless clubs have full bar and then
full nude clubs don't have alcohol so
where i always worked was topless with
uh full bar
so drinking all the time
and then um
smoking smoking weed of course
uh and then you know with with the late
hours you know there's there's a lot of
other stuff that's floating around a lot
of pills uh coke is really
popular
uh luckily luckily meth was not really
big in in the club that i was at in the
area i was at but i've been to other
clubs where it has and that
that runs rampant through clubs
but um
what made you get clean
mostly it was just kind of it was the
drinking initially drive driving home
and just
it all it all just started piling on and
adding up i was um
spent a couple a couple of times in the
er
and uh i actually had a doctor
kind of take me aside and say
give yourself six months
step away
let your body kinda
recover
and give yourself six months and then
re-evaluate things and then go from
there
and then
that six months has just now become
four 16 years eight i'm not gonna have
math but a long time that's great uh i
think 14 years but it just
through those six months
i just started noticing so many changes
uh i i i had more money i
was alert i was remembering things i i
was in a better mood and i actually got
promoted at my job i was paying more
attention to what i was doing so just
everything just started just
i noticed everything around me improving
and so i just kind of
stuck with it your life worked out
better very much so my my life has
completely turned around and none of
that would have happened if i didn't
get sober back then and it all just came
from six months and
i continued working in the club for
another 10 years after that which is
a whole other challenge
you know to getting sobers is is
the first part but then remaining sober
is
is the the
definitely the more difficult part when
you're still
you know
a lot of people you just don't go to the
bar
and that help you know but when your job
is the bar
it it's it's pretty difficult so it
takes quite quite a lot of willpower but
definitely worth it yeah do you have
kids
no kids no kids
no kids
do you have any regrets in your life
i have lots of regrets um
kind of the the typical answer from what
i've realized now
through through in in i don't say the
later part of my life but i in the
middle part of my life here i've figured
out the only regrets you have are the
things you don't do
which is you know typically what people
say
you know it's that's kind of like the
deathbed thing people say that's the
only thing i regret and it's it's really
true i
there's things that i've done that
i wish i had done differently or i wish
i hadn't done but i wouldn't necessarily
say it's a regret
because some of the worst moments of my
life
have led me to
some of the greatest moments and
greatest changes of my life
so
so
even even the bad times i wouldn't have
any regrets
and that's why now in my life i just try
to do everything i can take every
opportunity
and and in the past couple years that's
what i've done
and it's really taken me
i i was starting to feel kind of 18
years in the strip club i was feeling
really kind of
stuck in it
and then in the past
two years i've started working on a live
streaming
internet show
uh i've joined a few different bands one
of which i was a fan of myself when i
was growing up back in
junior high
that's a band called green jelly uh back
in the 90s they had a song called three
little pigs that was a pretty big song
in the mtv days uh i i've been able to
become very good friends with the the
singer of that band
and i joined the band and now
him and i and a group of our friends we
put on a weekly
kind of a weekly variety show it's like
a punk rock hee-haw kinda
but um it's it's just it's
a whole bunch of creative people coming
together and
probably three quarters of us are all
sober so it's it's a really would that
be happening for you if you had not
gotten sober
i i don't it wouldn't
because being sober and the way my life
has gone since that has led me to where
i am now and had i not done that i'd
still be out in my small little desert
town
working at the same club that i worked
at for 12 years
getting drunk
waking up at some time in the afternoon
and then doing it all over again
stuck in that
circle you know and then um
luckily i found my way out in my and my
way out was
getting sober essentially what are you
what are you afraid of no at this point
in your life snakes
i am afraid of snakes and i'm afraid of
heights
um which is funny everybody always
whenever i say that they always say but
you do suspension you put hooks in
yourself i said well it's
it's completely not the same thing like
one's a thing that'll bite me and the
other and
uh what do you worry about what do i i
worry about
um what are you afraid of
i you know i honestly i don't think i i
don't really take much time to think
about worries at this point
um
i i all you know i'm i mean i worry
about my friends and my family and i
want them all to be safe and i want them
all to be happy other than that
i really you know what's more important
than that yeah there's not that that's
the most important thing and then as far
like taking every opportunity i can
you can't let fear get in the way of
that you know because if you have any
fear at all you're not going to
take a step or make a move you know so
yeah i believe fear is one of the
biggest problems we have
definitely fear uh fear fear leads to a
lot of
you know depression depression and then
that leads to you know substance abuse
and all that type of stuff and and it it
does it all comes back to fear so
i i
i guess yeah i can't really think of
anything
i mean years ago of course i had fears
and i had concerns but now with my with
this new mindset of just going for
everything
my my only fear is that i'm gonna
miss out on miss something that i'm i'm
not gonna go for something what would
you say tyler is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um the most important lesson i've
learned is just to
just to be a good person and just to
worry about yourself and just
take care of your own life you know
treat other people well and if someone
needs help then help them but don't
concern yourself with
other people's
world you know you've got your own world
to
create and how you want to and
yeah excellent tyler thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah absolutely
thank you uh for having me i'm glad that
we got to sit down and have this talk
yeah i'm glad things are going well yes
right
you